more than a hundred American
firefighters are in Australia to help
get the country's massive bushfires
under control so far nearly 28 million
acres have burned an area almost the
size of Louisiana that's about 16 times
the amount of land that burned during
California's worst fire season in 2018
Jamie yuccas met with some of the
Americans who left their families and
traveled across the Pacific to join the
fight the American firefighters we spoke
to have spent decades fighting wildfires
across the west they say they can't
believe the amount of destruction these
fires have caused in Australia you can
see how flames just ripped through this
area and the damage goes on for miles
the Americans who come to Australia to
help with the massive firefighting
effort say this is nothing like they've
ever seen what have you been surprised
by the extent of this of this fire the
length of it the depth of it and then
the amount of structures that's impacted
it's pretty breathtaking we'll fly this
one hour and we will never get out of
the burn area Jay Carl is helping
coordinate air operations he left his
family behind in Colorado including his
seven month old son to lend his support
I do miss him a lot and you know
thinking about having four more weeks
three and a half more weeks over here it
gets challenging but we have technology
and you know FaceTime his family sends
in videos to keep his spirits up but
live communication with the 18 hour time
difference is difficult the windows are
very narrow sometimes you're hoping you
can get two minutes in just to say good
night to the kids and you know good
night to your loved ones
American firefighters in Australia are
facing new terrain new terminology like
rafters we don't even have those back
home and a shift in tactics because of
the sheer scale of these bush fires
Jason Loomis works for the US National
Park Service as a fire management
specialist when you learned you were
coming here yeah what went through your
mind oh yeah I was super excited but at
the same time pretty anxious we saw the
coverage for explosive conditions when
we were
being deployed and then you're going to
a foreign country so there's little
subtle nuances that you have to contend
with it's not the first time crews from
the two countries have worked together
I'm Michael
Australians have helped battle American
blazes in the past Americans were
cheered when they arrived in Sydney last
week fire management officer Bart kick
lighter was among them how did that feel
to get such a warm reception it felt
really good it felt like we were
respected as we respect them and it felt
good to be able to come over here and
return the favor to fight fire over here
for Australian fire fighter Marc
Williams the feeling is mutual
how have the Americans been to work with
fantastic okay the experts in their
field they've fitted in seamlessly
it's always funny it's a bit of a new
accent the pop of not a fire finding is
far funny
well battling wildfires is challenging
no matter where you are in the world
Australia's thick brush hotter than
normal temperatures and low humidity
have created the perfect fire storm
we weren't knowing for sure what we were
getting into we just knew that it was
chaotic and it was you know bigger and
greater than anything we had ever seen I
think just all the conditions came
together in a line and it's what we're
seeing here and we could see something
similar at home we certainly could
whether we see a million acre fire or
not I don't know
I certainly hope not but certainly the
conditions are there for it
the American crews are here for 30 days
there are still many hot spots that need
to be put out
and while better weather conditions are
predicted for this week it is only the
beginning of Australia's fire season so
more Americans could be asked to come
over in the next several months for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Nara Australia
you